Jared Kushner Jared Kushner has admitted
that Donald Trump lies to his own
followers because he thinks they're
stupid let me lay this out for you and
the background of course is you probably
know Trump was one of the most prominent
proponents of the birther theories that
President Obama wasn't a natural-born
American citizen that he was born in who
knows we're right Kenya Indonesia
wherever no evidence of that Obama
released his birth certificate the
entire thing was bogus
Trump clung to this likely racially
tinged claim for years and during most
of the election whenever an interviewer
would ask Trump about it he would say
add as an old issue nobody's talking
about that anymore
blah blah blah just sort of trying to
avoid the question it wasn't until
September of 2016 at a press conference
that Donald Trump finally conceded that
yes okay Obama was born in the United
States it wasn't ever a shocking
revelation and it was especially not
shocking in September of 2016
Jared Kushner is of course Donald
Trump's son-in-law senior advisor he's
quickly becoming a bigger and bigger
part of the Russia investigation Kushner
is another one of these real estate
investors who's wealthy because of the
success of his parent he also owns
newspapers okay that's the background on
Kushner Elizabeth Spears who's the
founder of Gawker and was the editor of
one of Kushner's newspapers the New York
Observer from 2011 to 2012 she said that
when she was working for Kushner the two
of them had an interesting conversation
that she recently recalled on Twitter
where she said quote when I was the
editor of the New York Observer Kushner
and I were going back and forth about
how the paper should cover Donald Trump
I told Jared that I was particularly
appalled by his father-in-law's
birtherism stance which I viewed as
cynical and racist he rolled his eyes
and said he doesn't really believe it
Elizabeth he just knows Republicans are
stupid and they'll buy it this is
fascinating partially because as with
much of what goes on with Trump many of
us already assumed Trump thought that
his base was stupid but I was never sure
whether or not Trump believed his own
nonsense about the birther stuff I
actually don't know what would be worse
Pat a having a present
that believes something as stupid and
unfounded as a birther conspiracy theory
or be having a president who manipulates
their base by lying to them because he
knows they're idiots and so easily
manipulable it's like you're picking
your poison at that point I think I mean
this is part of the reason why Trump was
able to win he was able to address a
group of impressionable naive people and
really communicate with them in a plain
spoken way and promise them everything
the same thing he did with his
businesses with Trump University in his
golf course it's a big con job obviously
though committed Trump fans will hear us
talking about this and they'll say oh
but David it's fake news but even if
this was 100% verified I know that it's
something that the editor of Kushner's
newspapers said happened even if it was
100% verified it would still make no
difference Donald Trump's fans would
still love him just like the whole if I
shoot someone on Fifth Avenue they'll
still like me thing Trump could directly
disparage his supporters and they
wouldn't mind they'd probably just
assume he's talking about some other
supporters not them after all remember
this gem from Donald Trump we won the
evangelicals we won with young we won
with old we won with highly educated we
won with poorly educated I love the
poorly educated so this is a sort of
offhanded revelation but it does tie
into something we've been talking about
and this is really the sort of serious
aspect of this Donald Trump's
authoritarian dictatorial tendencies
this is a standard right-wing populist
dynamic between a Trump and his
supporters they're the lowly masses
whose minds are totally malleable and
Trump is the brilliant genius who's
going to fix everything and show them
the way knowing that he can trick them
with bizarre and outlandish slides and
you know what there is some truth to
what Donald Trump is saying there study
after study has shown that liberals are
more educated on balance more
knowledgeable about what's going on in
the world at the net and that people
with authoritarian political beliefs are
less not less knowledgeable more
malleable and overall less intelligent
really all you have to do is look at
what's advertised on Infowars
right wing AM radio stations are
liberals going to buy male and female
vitality pills the way that Alex Jones
fans are buying them will the
progressive audience make you rich by
buying your anthro Plex supplements for
30 bucks for a little bottle because it
contains such ingredients as horny goat
weed and zinc orotate Trump is right to
some degree right I think it's
completely disingenuous do we actually
believe that Donald Trump is against
abortion or thinks that women should be
punished if they have abortions I don't
know the acts truly believe that wages
are too high in this country I don't I
don't think so and I think everything
we've seen from Trump and the fact that
he's backed off is it fair to say 1520
major campaign promises that are just no
longer a priority or just practically
not going to happen it was entirely
strategic for him you know he wanted to
place himself in a position where he
could win sometimes I was taking the
populist approach yeah other times the
establishment approach and you know it
matters when you're talking about
people's health care or their tax rates
or whether or not they have access to an
abortion I mean this isn't just a game
you know it's not I mean saying oh yeah
maybe women should be punished for
abortions and then oh you know what I
actually didn't mean that because he
really had no personal he was feeling
around for what would play best with the
most number of people he could bamboozle
into voting for him and he bamboozled
tens of millions of people into voting
for him